[Norvig] Now, suppose we arrange our program like this.
So we set up the houses and we have a list of all 120 possible orderings
and then we iterate each of the 5 properties in each of the 5 property groups
through all those orderings.
And so now, 5 levels nested deep into our code we've got an assignment
of all 25 properties.
Each of them is assigned to one of the houses,
and now we can check the constraints, like the Englishman lives in the red house
and the Spaniard owns the dog and so on. Those can all go here.
If we find something that checks out, we can just report we've got an answer.
Now, I want you to go back to the back of your envelope
and tell me if we wrote the program this way and filled in this code with all the constraints
and then ran it, about how long do you think it would take to find a solution?
About a second, a minute, an hour, or a day? Click on the best answer.